tonight US Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo is meeting with Russian Foreign
Minister Sergei Lavrov the meeting comes
right after new sanctions have been
leveled against Russian company and
three Russian individuals for supporting
the Syrian government of Bashir Assad
now sanctions apparently is an
interesting word to bring up here
because we've been working on this story
since this morning Michele Greenstein
our special correspondent here in the
news with rick sanchez joins us now
interesting dichotomy for these two men
to suddenly come together just as the
united states is leveling more sanctions
against russia i don't imagine that went
over so well with mr. Lavrov sure i mean
here we have these two leaders meeting
on the sidelines of the UN General
Assembly first time they've met since
last May but at the same time the u.s.
did just level new sanctions against
these Russian entities for the alleged
fuel sales to Syria they the US says
this is because Russia has been quote
supporting Assad's brutal war machine in
Syria and these are sanctions on one
Russian company five Russian flag
vessels and three Russian individuals
for the facilitating of the transfer of
jet fuel to Syria now yesterday is when
mr. Pompeo announced these new sanctions
and also said that since Syria has
allegedly you know chemically attacked
their own citizens yet again that the
United States will quote not allow these
attacks to go unchallenged and by the
way this is the 75th round of sanctions
that's been taken by the u.s. against
Russia since 2011 but according to the
Russian Foreign Ministry Sergey Lavrov
told Pompeo today that these this type
of sanction pressure on Russia is
absolutely useless and he says sees this
as just the latest step in the u.s.
acting unilaterally when it should be
acting multilaterally yeah you know it's
an interesting question remember back
during the Bush administration a lot of
people around the world because of the
Iraq debacle started referring to the
United States as having a cowboy
mentality and now during the Trump
administration I think less because of
mr. Trump had more because of some of
his minions a lot of people are calling
it a bully mentality do you get the
sense from Lavrov or from the Russians
that that kind of reaction is what
they're feeling as well like we've heard
from the Chinese
the Syrians and the Iranians etc sure
well if you read the Russian Foreign
Minister Lavrov a most recent article
that came out just a couple days ago
he says just that he actually says that
he thinks the international community is
on its way to a more just system because
of the quote unquote arrogant
neo-colonial policies that are being
used by the United States those are his
words Lavrov said those are his say that
again arrogant neo-colonial policies
here's another quote he says that that's
what's being used to quote empower
certain countries to impose their will
on others end quote so what he's doing
is condemning this rhetoric on
liberalism democracy and human rights
and he says this kind of rhetoric and
this kind of cloaking of human rights
and democracy to further you know the
us's agenda is responsible he said this
for the suffering of the Iraqis Syrians
Libyans as well as others and he says
that these political regimes that the
west proclaims to be undemocratic a
liberal or authoritarian are really just
a regimes that the US would like to
further control
Pompeyo interesting person isn't he I
mean he what did you sense of his
demeanor I know the Syria question is a
very important one and it's important to
the United States but he's he's got his
own way that sometimes it's almost more
Bolton esque than Trump esque sure well
he hasn't held back I mean this is not
really new for Pompeo Pompeo has been
talking tough on Russia for the entire
year now as well as on China on Iran he
really doesn't hold back in his rhetoric
but I think what's important to talk
about is the backdrop to these tops
because yes the US did just sanction
Russia for their you know alleged
fuelling of Syria the Syrian government
in this Syrian war which some call a
civil war in some call a us-led war on
Syria but this war on Syria which by the
way is in its ninth year now has two
very different narratives going on one
by the US and one supported by Russia
the US says it's only there to fight
Islamic extremism right but the Russia
sees its policy in Syria as their fight
against what they call international
terrorism in Syria so we got these
conflicting narratives so what I'd like
to do is bring a narrative from someone
on the ground from someone from Syria
and this is a quote from a book called
voices from Syria this is from a Syrian
living in Syria at the time let's take a
into this open we had a free school and
university education before the war
available for everyone free healthcare
no controlled bank life before the
crisis was so beautiful here
now it's hard and horrific in some
regions I do not understand how the good
and brave American people can accept to
bomb my country which has never harmed
them and helped the Barbarian al Qaeda
these animals slit throats and behead
for pleasure if there were to be a world
war many will die Iran will go to war
Russia and China eventually if it
escalates and all of this for what for
the elites who created al Qaeda through
the u.s. and use it to conduct proxy
wars and destabilize countries which do
not go along with their agenda American
people regain control of your ones
admirable country ask the Iraqis the
Afghan ease the Pakistanis the
Palestinians the Syrians and more all
the ones your government kills with
drones every day stop the wars use
diplomacy not dialogue and I think
although this is not often for us to
know just bring us a random civilian
voice from the ground on our air I think
it's important to think about because we
have these two conflicting narratives
both Russia and the US are saying that
they're the ones involved in fighting
terrorism against Syria so Russia says
they're you know fighting us back what
about the series exactly I mean do the
Syrians say and this Syrian specifically
says that it's the u.s. that's
supporting al Qaeda and its affiliates
in an effort to destabilize the Syrian
government good stuff Michelle
interesting report full-throated and
very complete appreciate that so you
haven't heard that we're the ones
covering the stories that you won't see
covered anywhere else in Venezuela
kha'zix tab let's go to Hong Kong and
the media reaction to that has been
crickets how about the way we cover
those stories what the hell does that
mean Walla Walla Walla that's the key
word in this case uprising keep
watch it this is the right thing for
members of the media to do to actually
pick sides but if you like what you see
subscribe